[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver avec ce soir
deux médecins mais pas que puisque nous
avons le plaisir de d'avoir sur notre
plateau par ordre alphabétique laurent
alexandre bonsoir et vous êtes médecin
chirurgien vous est aussi entrepreneur à
succès essayiste et le votre dernier
livre
jouissez jeunesse a été publié aux
éditions lattès et puis le docteur
patrick peloux bonsoir médecin
urgentiste président de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france
vous avez publié aux éditions du cherche
midi une sélection de vos chroniques à
charlie hebdo ça s'appelle urgence de
vivre alors comme parfois des
internautes qu'ils disent mais le dr
pelloux il est toujours sur des plateaux
alors est-ce qu'il a le temps de bosser
eh bien oui je vous annonce ainsi pas il
ne le dira pas par modestie que ce matin
patrick peloux à vacciner 80 personnes à
l'hôtel dieu où vous êtes aux 700 postes
les personnels avec les infirmières et
les personnels nous allons commencer le
justement pas reparlé de cette pandémie
avec une annonce surprise du maire de
perpignan louis aliot qui a indiqué
vouloir réouvrir dès demain les quatre
musées de sa ville avec un protocole
sanitaires très strictes annonce-t-il
jauge maximum un espace de 10 mètres
carrés minimum par visiteur un sens de
circulation alors il est probable que le
préfet ne le laissera pas prendre cette
initiative car elle est totalement en
contradiction avec les
et consignes gouvernementales écoutez
roselyne bachelot c'est la ministre de
la culture elle était ce matin sur bfm
tv et pour elle dans la réouverture
c'est pas pour tout de suite
nous nous préparons effectivement avec
cette réouverture le plus rapidement
possible des musées des monuments pour
moi les conditions se sont que le nombre
de contaminations et la pression sur le
système hospitalier soit dans une
logique dans un mouvement de décrue
or on n'y est pas patrick pelloux évoqué
un homme de gauche est ce que pour une
fois vous seriez d'accord avec un avec
un élu du rassemblement national et non
mais c'est pas c'est pas parce qu'il
faut bien sûr voilà ses idées je suis
parce que vous ne l est pas bonne parce
que je veux dire pourquoi elle et pas
bonne elle n'est pas bonne parce que
justement quelqu'un qui veut être dans
un élan politique qui est quand même
populistes et qui portent en fait des
idées très républicaine et l'ordre comme
ça d'être un électron libre je trouve
que c'est quelque chose qui va pas avec
finalement l'image qu'ils veulent donner
bon ceci dit une idée est pas si
mauvaise que ça parce que et ça reprend
une tribune qui a été fait dans le temps
dans le figaro par l'acteur patrick
mille qui est de dire il va falloir et
ça je le crois profondément pas falloir
commencer à relancer la société et à
apprendre à vivre
j'en suis convaincu avec cette nouvelle
maladie faut sortir du dogme de dire que
c'est juste une épidémie qui est passé
comme ça sur une année et qui va s'en
aller
elle va pas s'en aller parce que vous
avez des variants qui vont revenir et
c'est peut-être est-ce le nouveau
concept de la nouvelle grippe du nouveau
millénaire donc ça veut dire que des
personnalités politiques qui commencent
à dire va falloir rouvrir notamment les
objets de cultures notamment les objets
ce2 et les salles de sport par exemple
tout ça je crois qu'il faut qu'il y ait
ce débat c'est pour ça que moi même je
pense que les différents ministères
devraient faire le tour de table avec
les professionnels pour justement trouvé
une bonne adéquation entre des gestes
barrières qui vous
finir par s'incruster dans notre société
pour les mois voire les années qui
viennent
d'accord mais reprendre une activité et
juste à un mot évidemment ça a été je
comprends comme d'un coup on a dit que
la culture n'était pas essentiel je
pense que la culture est profondément
essentiel c'est là où j'aurais tendance
à rejoindre ce le maire de père de
perpignan parce que en fait on a besoin
de culture on a soif lancement la soif
de culture on a soif d'aller au musée on
a soit de se promener on a soif d'être
aéré et et de voir les choses et c'est
vrai que si vous voulez les remarques
qui sont faites quand on voit il y avait
des commerces vont là ils ont fermé les
commerces de qui était assez grand parce
que les gens étaient trop serrés dans
les centres commerciaux les centres
commerciaux
bon eh ben il va falloir développer ça
j'espère que le fameux concert tests
dont tout le monde parle actuellement
puisse avoir lieu à paris pour tester et
voir combien de gens risquent de se
contaminer dans une foule etc tout ça on
est au début d'un apprentissage pour
vivre avec cette maladie
mais le concept de réouvrir les lieux de
culture et les lieux un peu conviviaux
se pose maintenant tu vraiment de
manière importante et je crois qu'il
faut plus gouvernement en tienne compte
et pourtant le gouvernement il a souvent
des échos qui sont exactement l'inversé
des vôtres y compris de médecins aussi
réputés que le professeur arnaud
fontanet épidémiologistes
lui aussi il était sur bfm tv
aujourd'hui et il nous affirme que
compte tenu de la dangerosité du patient
anglais non c'est pas possible on ne
peut pas rouvrir des lieux comme les
musées regarder avec cette situation
extrêmement volatile du varié en anglais
je pense que des quand même obligé
d'observer donc vous l'avez compris le
gouvernement ne varia anglais nous
empêche d'ouvrir quoi que ce soit et
nous oblige à une extrême prudence
on est sur une ligne de crête
l'essentiel pour moi c'est de suivre
très très près la progression du baril
anglais si on voit que ça tiens pourquoi
pas si on voit qu'il continue sur une
progression
il faudra un moment ou un autre pas sa
démission oui georges ont alors
alexandre fait partie des prudents comme
professeur fontanet ou les ou d'aidés
volontariste comme le docteur pelloux
moi je suis plus proche de l avait dit
dans le passé déjà mais le fait que
yelle variés anglais ça foutait pas
changé d'avis le vario anglais
problématique mais vous avez vu quel
rythme de vaccination
d'ailleurs dans vos colonnes avec
nicolas bouzou et levier babeau il ya
quelques jours nous allons publier un
papier sur le plantage la commission
européenne comme il n'y a pas de vaccin
et que on va arriver à l'immunité
collective à l'automne seulement nous
avons neuf mois devant nous on va pas
mettre les français sous bulle pendant
neuf mois sous prétexte que la
commission européenne n'a pas bien n'a
pas correctement commander les vaccins
donc il va bien falloir trouver un
intermédiaire entre la politique
la grogne des gens qui en ont marre
d'être confiné et puis la santé publique
d'épidémiologie
ça va être un arbitrage difficile de
tout mettre sous cloche jusqu'en
septembre octobre
ce n'est plus possible dire qu'il ya un
moment où fontanet réseau sur le plan
épidémiologique on est sur la ligne de
crête
mais l'opinion ne va pas supporter qu'on
le ferme tout donc il va falloir lâcher
des choses est l'un des endroits à mon
avis où on peut avoir la plus grande
distanciation social c'est bien usé et
donc je pense qu'il faut ré ouvrir les
musées
les endroits où le risque de
contamination est relativement faible
je pense que c'est une erreur d'avoir
fermé les grands magasins parce que la
cocotte minute va finir par péter moi ça
me rappelle ce qui s'est passé au début
des années 80 au début des années 80 on
avait donné comme message aux jeunes que
bien sûr les rapports sexuels et des
contaminants pour le sida mais que la
fellation aussi est très contaminante et
qu'il ne fallait pas faire deux
fellations sans préservatif
et puis finalement les gens ne
respectaient plus rien parce que le sexe
était insupportable et on a changé à
nouveau la communication on a fini par
dire bon le risque d' a fait la scion
n'est pas totalement nuls mais il est
insignifiant donc on vous autorise à
continuer la fellation sans préservatif
alors que d'un point de vue strictement
médical il ya un petit risque de
transmettre le sida avec la fellation et
ben là c'est la même chose
d'un point de vue purement
épidémiologique il faut tout bouclé
jusqu'à noël prochain
mais d'un point de vue politique il va
bien falloir lâcher du lest et le musée
vraiment de mon point de vue un endroit
où le risque d'être contaminé faible y'a
quoi la culture ménanteau l'ouverture
des musées juste je vous passe la parole
à patrick mais la vider nos internautes
qui sont sondés via twitter peut-on se
permettre de rouvrir les musées c'est la
question que nous vous posons et vous
répondez oui à 76% tant que ça c'est la
question de twitter du jour et puis
voici quelques réflexions bien sûr nous
dit bouillie sur twitter il faut miser
sur le principe de responsabilité et
tout ira bien
cessons d'infantiliser les français
sofiane est d'accord sur youtube les
musées participent au bien être
psychologique
il faut donc les rouvrir dans des
conditions strictes à licence sur
twitter nous dit vous êtes gentils enfin
bon ça c'est moi qui rajoute il vous dit
la question ne concerne que les
métropoles dans les petites villes de
province
on se moque des musées car il n'y en a
pas il faut rouvrir les restos et les
signer et puis elle a qui ajoute sur
lefigaro.fr sachant qu'il n'y a presque
plus de touristes étrangers
il y aura forcément moins de monde ce
serait une bonne décision du
gouvernement il ya encore d'autres
réactions mais patrick peloux aussi veut
s'exprimer mois oui ça fait un an qu'on
est
dans ce problème là moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya deux mondes
en fait dans le monde médical
en fait qui s'affrontent maintenant
ouvertement médias interposés vous avez
ce qu'ils veulent et qu'ils ont quelque
part goûté au pouvoir
je pèse mes mots c'est à dire qu'il y en
a qui ont goûté au pouvoir a ce pouvoir
incroyable de dire comme j'ai le savoir
j'ai le pouvoir et le pouvoir je vais
l'utiliser et probablement c'est dans
l'histoire de france
une page qui a été tourné avec des
médecins qui se sont dit voilà je peux
prendre le pouvoir et dire regardez par
exemple c'est intéressant de voir le
président de la république qui c'est qui
a pris la parole et moi je soutiens ce
qu'il a dit quand il a dit je ne
confirme pas etc
je pense qu'il a eu raison d'accords et
bien c'est quand même le doyen des
doyens des facultés de médecine
professeur yu qui a pris la parole en
disant c'est une erreur en prenant
d'ailleurs modestement en dix ans
comparant à churchill et en disant je
promet du sang et des larmes
donc vous avez un monde médical qui veut
avoir le pouvoir et qu'ils utilisent
justement les risques pour avoir et puis
vous avez un autre monde médical qui est
là pour accompagner des libertés dont je
vous assure je fais partie je pense que
laurent aussi c'est à dire que la
médecine elle est là pour accompagner
les libertés liberté de progrès liberté
de choisir sa mort d'accord et liberté
de vivre et je crois que là c'est là où
il ya vraiment et c'est là où les deux
plaques de ce ces deux mondes médicaux
sont en train de s'affronter
parce que en fait qu avons-nous fait
d'autre pendant tous ces mois que
d'anticiper une surcharge dans les
hôpitaux à et là on arrive à un truc
très important parce que en fait ce que
des personnes comme moi bien modestement
disent depuis des années on a fermé trop
de lignes notamment des lits de
réanimation
on est en dessous de l'allemagne on est
dans les derniers pays dos et des lits
de réanimation
là on veut fait que gérer la pénurie et
comme par hasard ceux qui prônent le
confinement sont ceux qui disent il faut
pas rouvrir de lits de réanimation mais
même si vous trouverez des livres et
vous allez pas l'avouer tout de suite
donc mais ça mais gérard comme un bio
les urgentistes comme vous qui
ça suffit maintenant ces médecins qui
nous font peur mais il faut continuer à
vivre le musée parce que je vois les
conséquences de tout ça je vois des gens
qui se sucrent vous ne l'avez dit déjà
j'ai vu en italie sur le terrain de
cette dame qui a entendu président de la
république du cas confinement elle ouvre
sa fenêtre elle saute
d'accord on a vu une augmentation on a
on a les appels des pédopsychiatres
disant que les mots ne vont pas bien
parce que les mômes ils vont plus voir
papy et mamie on les a confiné je suis
d'accord avec je suis plus court il
s'appelle la bouboule qui arrivent là
dit un truc là oui oui oui il a raison
les gens les gens mine de rien
rappelez-vous ce qu'on nous disait ah on
était là rappelez-vous ce qu'on nous
disait à noël on disait par les gens ils
vont être ensemble ils vont se
contaminer début janvier c'est la
catastrophe non les françaises et
français en effet ils sont responsables
ils sont beaucoup plus vaillant que ce
qu'on dit ils sont raisonnables ils
réfléchissent et juste pour terminer je
peux vous dire qu'ils réfléchissent
d'autant mieux que là ce matin quand
j'ai vacciner le nombre de gens qui me
disent alors comment je peux faire
vacciner mon oncle maintenant on va tout
le monde veut se faire vacciner et il
faut simplement que l'état et le
gouvernement prennent le taureau est en
effet comme à 10 ans a traîné son
excellente tribune alors il faut que
vraiment puissent vacciner tout le monde
j'ai fini vous disiez il ya
effectivement des médecins qui ont
peut-être pris goût à à ce pouvoir et
vous avez même des structures
officielles qui théoriquement dépendent
du gouvernement dans lesquels on entend
des voix totalement dissonante par
rapport à ce qu'est la politique
publique depuis
dix jours maintenant ce fameux vendredi
par vendre dès le dernier mais celui
d'avant où le premier ministre a surpris
tout le monde en disant on reconsidère
est pas regarder cette déclaration de
daniel lévy bruhl c'est le responsable
de l'unité infections respiratoires de
santé publique france et
l'administration en santé publique
français et il dit il va falloir des
mesures plus strictes que celles qui
sont aujourd'hui elles vont devenir
nécessaire laurent alexandre à ce que ça
vous choque ce genre de déclarations
vous qui avez aussi été haut
fonctionnaire parce que non seulement
vous êtes médecin vous avez fait hec
vous avez aussi fait l'ena écoutez vous
voyez bien que c'est extrêmement
difficile et qu'on est effectivement sur
un chemin de crête
moi je pense maintenant compte tenu du
fait qu'on va mettre beaucoup beaucoup
de temps à atteindre l'immunité
collective par le vaccin
je pense qu'il faut un autre chemin la
situation du gouvernement est difficile
1 donc il ne faut pas jeter la pierre
mais il faut qu'on réfléchisse en ce
moment à ouvrir des espaces de liberté
en maintenant une bonne distanciation je
fais ma question je veux déjà choqué par
le fait que des médecins qui sont soumis
au pouvoir politique parce qu'ils sont
des médecins de l'assistance publique
prennent position contre le gouvernement
c'est pas la première fois on a vu peron
expliqué que le gouvernement massacrer
la population française depuis on est là
on a dû foucher qui travaille à la paix
de marseille dans les hôpitaux publics 1
avec un statut de la fonction publique
qui explique qu'ils parlent de génocide
à propos de la politique gouvernementale
de vaccination dont les ehpad donc ce
que dit monsieur les vides etc de la
bibine par rapport à ce que ferrone et
et fouché ont pu raconter eux qui sont
aussi fonctionnaires dépendant de l'état
donc il ya des points de vue divergents
aujourd'hui il va falloir trouver une
synthèse
on ne peut pas maintenir la cocotte
minute comme ça jusqu'à la fin du
programme de vaccination
vu qu'on a un programme de vaccination
est escargot à cause de l'erreur qu'a
commise la présidente de la commission
européenne donc aujourd'hui il faut
inverser la problématique il faut ouvrir
tous les espaces de liberté pour éviter
que la cocotte-minute saute je suis
conscient que le variant britannique et
le variant sud africain et brésilien
pose des problèmes mais il va falloir
ouvrir et personnellement et pas
uniquement parce que j'aime beaucoup le
ski je pense que on pourrait ré ouvrir
les télésièges parce que le risque
d'être contaminé sur un télésiège est
vraiment faible
vous êtes d'accord je vous passe la
parole
patrick pelloux et vous êtes dans la
tonalité de la majorité des réactions de
nos internautes
dd sur youtube quoi qu'il arrive il
faudra vivre avec le co vide autant
rouvrir maintenant pourquoi donc les
musées le devant de christine sur
youtube
tout doit ouvrir tout simplement
alors il ya d'angres sur lefigaro.fr qui
est un petit peu moins enthousiaste qui
dit ça sert à rien de rouvrir si c'est
pour fermer de nouveau dans deux ou
trois semaines et puis tout body sur
lefigaro.fr
si les jo sont respectés dans les musées
comme dans les supermarchés c'est très
risqué juste dire par rapport à ce qu'a
déclaré le responsable de santé publique
france c'est qu'en plus vous avez une
guerre qui est que personne ne voit dans
les médias mais vous avez une guerre
entre santé publique france la haute
autorité de santé
les différents comités qui sont créé le
comité scientifique qui se tirent la
bourre avec le comité vaccinale et tout
ça tout ça parce que les médecins
peuvent pas dire qu'ils sont pas écartés
tout ça s'est dirigée par des docteurs
d'accord des docteurs qui ne sont pas du
tout dans la culture que vous aviez dans
les années cinquante huit quand le
général de gaulle a créé les centres
hospitalo universitaires ihu
il avait nommé des types qui avait une
grandeur et qui voyez le truc non non
non on a complètement chanter changé
avec des gens qui prônent de toute façon
est avant toute chose leur propre vanité
je les fréquente tout le temps à dos
donc du coup la voix ce que ce que je
croise où il ya vraiment une balance
maintenant il ya vraiment une balance et
vraiment je le crois profondément
entre la mortalité de lakovic 19 et le
risque la crise sociale qu'ont à la
solitude qui est le premier fléau de ce
truc là d'accord avec un mal être des
familles à mal être des enfants à vous
avez vous vraiment c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut porter la vie sociale la
convivialité les risques suicidaires
tout ça vous mettez la balance je peux
vous dire qu'il vaut mieux que le
gouvernement et c'est pour ça que je
soutiens le fait vraiment de ce qu'a
décidé le président de la butte et
castex ne part confinés comme ça et se
dire voilà on fait au cas par cas mais
il faut juste qu'il ya y est ça reprend
votre première question en fait qu' un
élan patriotique patriotisme c'est du
patriotisme qu'il faut en disant ok jeu
complètement d'accord avec laurent c'est
de dire voilà c'est simple relance le
truc on trouve on se met autour de la
table qu'est ce qu'un restaurant avec
une distanciation
oui il y en a ils pourront pas
forcément ouvrir mais trouveront des
solutions comme on rouvre les musées
comme on retrouve les salles de
spectacle comme on rouvre les théâtres
comment comment on arrive parce que vous
savez là on a mis l'accent notamment sur
les étudiants mais comment on retrouve
les universités des facs
c'est une saison on a une société qui
est pas fait pour être confiné advitam
eternam c'est pas ça la vie c'est pas ça
la vie voilà on rappelle que cette
détresse sociale comme urgentiste vous
êtes aux premières loges à la
heureusement pour la mesurer
concrètement on change complètement le
sujet si vous le voulez bien
le nouveau haut commissaire au plan
françois bayrou qui est aussi maire de
pau était hier l'invité du grand jury
rtl le figaro lci et le l'animateur de
l'émission benjamin sporto je tiens à me
poser la question mais quand est-ce
qu'on est quand est-ce qu'on est riche
en france et voilà le dialogue entre un
conte à partir de combien les tons
riches
bah ça dépend si on parle du patrimoine
de 2 il y en avait de ses 15000 euros
par mois dont françois hollande avait
dit en son temps c'est 4000 euros par
mwh 4000 euros pas mois pour moi ces
classes moyennes
voilà on se souvient que c'était en 2006
celui qui n'était pas encore président
de la république a affirmé qu'
effectivement les riches c'était ce
qu'il y avait un salaire de plus de 4000
euros net par mois alors factuellement
françois bayrou à tort s'il parle de 2
du salaire individuel puisque le salaire
moyen en france il est de 2200 38 euros
et le salaire médian avec le salaire
médian c'est quand vous avez la moitié
des gens qui sont au dessus et l'autre
moitié qui est en dessous il est à 1789
euros cela dit le même françois bayrou a
expliqué que après l'émission que ce
qu'il entendait par 4000 euros c'était
pour un couple sans que c'était deux
fois 2000 euros et là on est à peu près
dans le salaire des classes moyennes le
salaire des classes moyennes c'est à
dire des 50% qui sont au milieu pour un
couple avec deux enfants de plus de 14
ans c'est entre 3400 et 6200 donc donc
avec 4000 euros monde est à peu près au
milieu mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
les réactions considérable sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'ont provoqué cette
déclaration on en prend une mais on
pourrait en prendre 29 celle d'olivier
fort le patron du parti socialiste qui
dit oui comment comprendre les gilet
jaune quand on pense que les français
gagnent en moyenne 4000 euros par mois
est ce que c'est parce qu'il a dit quoi
c'est pas ce qu'il a dit là il n'ya pas
il y là il a parlé des classes moyennes
pas du salaire moyen
il a dit logan 1000 euros par mois c'est
la classe moyenne fédérale paradis n'est
pas le salaire salaire moyen est de
serrer la vis efforts se trompe c'est
vrai mais on est quand même pas te
prépares très très éloignées ce qui est
incroyable
laura l'excusé de notre pays dès qu'on
commence à parler d'argent et de ce
qu'on appelle les riches ça a déclenché
des polémiques
vous en pensez quoi je rappelle que vous
êtes entrepreneur avait beaucoup de
succès dans votre vie notamment la
création du site doctissimo que vous
avez revendu au groupe lagardère et ce
qui était parfaitement justifié ça vous
a permis de on va dire de faire fortune
pour faire court le sujet passionnel à
chacun sa névrose
en belgique là où j'habite la névrose
elle et linguistique on s'étripe sur le
fait d'être flamand et de parler
néerlandais ou d'être francophone en
france c'est l'argent l'équivalent de la
névrose linguistique à bruxelles et bas
à paris c'est la guerre entre les riches
et les pauvres et c'est une névrose
collective c'est une névrose nationale
il faut la respecter
en france on se construit sur la haine
des riches dans dans la société et donc
ce débat il est récurrent il est très
ancien il est assez spécifique à la
france on n'a bien évidemment pas la
même chose en angleterre on n'a pas la
même chose aux états unis je pense qu'il
faut respecter les névroses national
patrick peloux ça ça vous a choqué ses
déclarations de françois bayrou
non non non parce que remise dans son
contexte c'est et on voit que en fait la
classe politique soit hollande ou béroud
en gros il ya un truc qui les titille
sur les classes moyennes et les 4000 et
les fameux 4000 euros moi qui travaille
dans le service public
voilà je n'ai pas de regarde de jalousie
et je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
gens il ya des gens qui gagnent de
l'argent voilà il ya des gens qui
gagnent de l'argent et qui savent gagner
de l'argent et et on va pas les rendre
coupable du reste ce qui ne va pas c'est
la répartition des richesses et
justement ce qui fait que d'un coup ce
que je vois parce que c'est tout à fait
légitime de vouloir plus d'argent
le la des succès du ségur de la santé
pour parler de la santé ce que je
possède le mieux c'est quand le
gouvernement a dit d'accord banco on
vous file 190 euros de plus par mois ce
qui moi à mon avis devrait le doublé
cette année mais bon c'est autre chose
en fait on s'apercevait tout le monde en
avait convaincu que vous aviez un le
métier l'un des métiers les plus
populaires avec sapeurs-pompiers en
france c'est les infirmières bon on
était à la 28e place 26e place des pays
de l' ocde sur la rémunération des
infirmières alors là vous êtes en
dessous des 4000 euros par mois à
c'était vraiment c'était pas bon
bon et quand on disait ça donc il ya un
an un an et cinq mois et je me souviens
je m'en étais entretenu avec agnès buzyn
je me dis mais augmenter les salaires de
300 euros par mois pour les infirmières
des aides-soignantes les personnels
hospitaliers et comme ça on fait de
rattrapage
c'était une fin de non-recevoir c'était
impossible impossible j'ai eu que vous
allez voir jouer on a un âge où je vais
en arriver il ya la crise et tout il ya
le ségur et là hop on dit oui pour les
augmenter ses rêves bon ce qui fait que
quand des gens vous disent qu'on a on
frôle on a 10 millions de pauvres en
france que vous avez vraiment des
fractures et c'est qu'ils vont pas quand
vous avez des secteurs qui disent il
faut augmenter les salaires parce que
c'est en adéquation avec les tâches de
travail et aux mairies et aux berit et
notamment sur les heures supplémentaires
eh bien il faut le faire ce qui fait que
vous avez en fait un ascenseur de
compréhension une fracture névrotique
way qui est vraiment profonde est en
fait le système
m à la faire perdurer c'est à dire que
par exemple quand vous avez là là à
l'heure actuelle je vous raconte ce
juste une anecdote à l'assistance
publique ils réfléchissent à savoir si
on va pas faire une prime collective
d'intéressement au personnel
si jamais ils travaillent bien d'accord
le truc c'est kafkaïen d'accord moi je
leur ai juste répondu payer les heures
supplémentaires que vous devez au
personnel et tout le monde sera content
vous pose la question sur twitter et
tons riches en gagnant quatre mille
euros par mois et bien c'est non à 59%
4000 euros pour un couple avec un enfant
c'est très juste surtout s'il faut se
loger dans une grande ville
pendant ce we commente ironie mise sur
twitter c'est vrai d'ailleurs presque
impossible aujourd'hui à paris quand on
a quand on a quand on est un couple avec
deux enfants et 4000 euros
jacques sur twitter nos missions n'est
pas forcément riches on n'est pas pauvre
pour autant on peut vivre bien et puis
cette phrase pleine de sagesse de nico
sur youtube la plus belle richesse c'est
de se contenter de ce qu'on a c'est vrai
mais c'était plus difficile
nico canton n'étant quand on est en bas
de la hiérarchie des revenus est trop
riche s'est dépensé sans vraiment se
soucier des fins de mois 4000 euros sepa
riche du tout nous disais fille sur
twitter le rang les corps est ce que
finalement les français ne se sont pas
faussement converti à l'acceptation
d'aider des différences de richesse on
avait dit qu'il y avait eu un changement
fort avec emmanuel macron parce qu'il
avait travaillé dans le privé en plus à
la banque rothschild
parce qu'il annonçait qu'il allait
supprimer l' isf parce qu'il disait
c'est très bien de vouloir être
millionnaire quand il s'adressait à des
jeunes et on disait pas ça y est les
français ont changé l'état d'esprit
et puis finalement peut-être qu'on a
parlé un peu vite je crois que le vrai
problème c'est que la crispation autour
de l'argent ne va faire qu'augmenter
dans les années qui viennent parce que
comme la spécialisation industrielle de
la france recule le la richesse produite
par la france recule dire que au niveau
mondial la france comme ne cessent de
baisser en termes de production par
habitant
or comme on peut plus s'endetter parce
qu'il ya plus de sous si on gagne moins
et qu'on peut pas s'endetter le pouvoir
d'achat va baisser sinon n'améliore pas
notre compétitive et industriels
quand vous avez anne hidalgo qui bloque
la 5g à paris et qui s'oppose aux
industries modernes
quand vous avez un certain nombre de
dirigeants qui s'opposent aux
technologies génétiques qui s'opposent
aux industries high-tech qui donne des
gros salaires on appauvrit le pays donc
si on a si on continue à mépriser la
science si on
continue à mépriser la technologie à
désindustrialisé on va gagner de moins
en moins il faut savoir que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est
l'industrie qui donne des gros salaires
et les services à la personne qui donne
des petits salaires dans un pays où il
n'y a que des gens qui font du chemin la
personne le niveau de vie s'effondre
parce que c'est l'industrie qui donne
des gros salaires y compris aux gens peu
qualifiés y compris aux ouvriers un
ouvrier schiste à la chair du sein du ce
tri ça gagne plus que quelqu'un qui
travaille dans les services à la
personne qui sont par ailleurs très très
importante mais il ne peut pas y avoir
que ça dans une économie donc si on veut
diminuer les crispations
il faut que la production française
cesse de reculer par rapport aux autres
pays
donc il faut monter en gamme sur le plan
technologique et il faut développer
l'industrie française dans les
technologies du futur
or aujourd'hui on fait le contraire on
est de plus en en plus spécialisés dans
des secteurs peu technologie qui donne
des petits salaires
donc cette crispation ne va pas
s'arranger si la france n'investit pas
davantage dans la recherche et dans les
hautes technologies signer je suis à
mille pour cent d'accord avec ça ce qui
est incroyable c'est que nicolas sarkozy
avait il y avait pensé en 2007
c'est lui qui d'un coup se dit il faut
réindustrialiser la france
on sort des années chirac où on a un peu
cassé le truc avec un départ absolument
rocambolesque dont milieu des années 80
par la gauche qui sacrifie ses aciéries
en disant 35 heure environ seulement
aidé non plus bon je crois que ça avait
savait pas grand chose à voir
d'accord le le monde industriel n'a pas
été aidé d'accord et d'un et d'un coup
là à l'heure actuelle ce qu'on voit
notamment avec la crise on a perdu notre
souveraine question de médicaments sur
le matériel médical de première
nécessité et c'est pour ça que d'un coup
d'entendre en fait castex qui j'en ai
une journée je vais plus parler avec lui
là dessus de réindustrialiser la france
ça doit être l'objectif numéro un
quand on sait que vous savez tout le
monde dit i find her father mais une
partie des chercheurs de chez pfizer
sont français sont français donc d'un
coup on n'est pas un pays médiocre on
est un pays
moi je le redis avec des gens qui ont
une histoire une histoire dans le monde
industriel une histoire dans mon dos la
recherche de la science et on a
l'impression qu'on nous
serrer le kiki depuis des années faut
libérer justement ces énergies relancer
le tissu et relancer l'industrie mais
c'est là où il y aura besoin du
patriotisme du medef parce que relancer
l'industrie ça veut dire relancer
l'emploi
les bons salaires comme dit laurent
forcément et pas forcément que les
dividendes c'est là où ça va pas revu
beaucoup de commentaires
ceux de nos internautes mathieu sur
youtube la plupart des gens qui touche
4000 euros par mois ne l'ont pas eue du
jour au lendemain juste en levant les
yeux au ciel c'est une juste récompense
du travail accompli
théodore sur twitter on ne fait certes
partie de la classe moyenne supérieure
quand on gagne cette somme là mais on
peut pas partir au ski ni dans des pays
en dehors de l'europe car trop cher on
s'en sort mais on est paré jeu même si
évidemment comparé à une personne au
smic
on est riche et puis nelson sur youtube
la richesse n'est pas seulement une
question de revenus mensuels il faut
aussi y intégrer le patrimoine et la
culture
laurent alexandre françois bayrou en
n'ayant cette réflexion vous pensez
qu'il était il a mis les pieds dans le
plat ou et c'était nécessaire pour
provoquer un débat où il faut mieux
éviter ce genre du sujet en france parce
que puisque ça fâche n'en parlons pas je
pense qu'il faut éviter le sujet mais il
faudrait tél il faut le traiter le
problème sur le fond le problème c'est
aujourd'hui d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat des classes populaires par l'art
et industrie est rien du tri-nations
garde regardez le résultat de la
désindustrialisation
l'année dernière on a acheté 6 milliards
et demi d'euros de masques à la chine
c'est énorme c'est absolument monstrueux
c'est plus que l'investissement total
qui a été fait dans modern art j'ai pour
mettre au point le vaccin est ré jeu
vous intéresse que j'ai enfin trouvé un
sujet des accords entre vous vous dites
il faut mieux pas en parler puisque de
façon ça énerve tout le monde de
l'argent vous vous n'êtes pas d'accord à
bombay je pense qu'il faut en parler moi
je pense qu'il faut en parler en parler
pour justement dire attendez il faut
sortir de cette espèce de noeud gordien
qui affole les classes sociales et qui
ne va pas du tout en disant voilà on va
refaire progresser tout le monde mais on
refait travail et on refait progresser
tout le monde
avec du travail avec du travail qui dans
la proximité qualifiée qui fait revivre
les régions d'accord il faut arrêter un
tout tout c'est toutes ces communes qui
ont investi de l'argent d'ailleurs du
contribuable souvent pour faire des
zones d'industrialisation m
zizou ou tout ce que vous voulez et qui
sont en fait des hangars vides
il faut repartir là dessus repartir sur
du travail et du travail soient
contemporains et il faut c'est très
clairement qu'il y ait un consensus
serait industrialisation à droite et à
gauche et que tout le monde soit
convaincu qu'il faut développer
l'industrie haut de gamme française bien
sûr merci beaucoup monsieur merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis point de vue c'est
fini pour ce soir on a déjà en retard
mais on se retrouvera demain c'est
promis à la même heure et au même
endroit
[Musique]